hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
titled coronavirus history biology and
innate immune antagonism
this webinar is part of the coronavirus
virtual event series
and i'm susie valdez of labyrinths and i
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by
lab roots so let's get started before we
begin i want to remind everyone
that this event is interactive and we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
during the presentation to do so simply
type it into the question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation if you
have any trouble seeing
or hearing this presentation just click
on that ask a question box located on
the far
left of your screen as a reminder this
presentation
is educational and offers continuing
education credits tab
click on the continuing education
credits tab located on the top
right corner of your presentation window
and follow the process to obtain those
credits
i now present today's speaker dr susan
weiss
professor and vice chair of the
department of microbiology
and co-director at penn center for
research on coronaviruses and other
emerging pathogens
at perlman school of medicine in the
university of pennsylvania
for complete biography of our speakers
please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen dr weiss
welcome
you may now begin your presentation
so i have a sort of abbreviated title
now coronavirus is old and new but i'm
going to
i'm going to cover the same topics that
susie just mentioned
so uh my talk's going to be divided into
two parts the first part part's going to
be a basic
discussion of the biology of
coronaviruses and i think that's
important to understand because
it helps us identify steps in the viral
life cycle that may serve as targets for
antivirals that will be
effective against uh both the curve
corona viruses that we know about and
any future coronaviruses
the second part of the talk is going to
be about the antagonism of the innate
immune responses
by coronaviruses and this is really
important also because during early
infection
coronaviruses are really good at
shutting down host
interferon responses and other similar
other pathways related pathways
however during later infection uh
cytokine
production becomes part of the pathology
as we all heard about these cytokine
storms so
my lab has had a long-term interest in
understanding the interaction of
coronaviruses with with these pathways
so let me get started
uh okay here's the chronov coronavirus
virion
it has a now familiar morphology i think
this is an electron microscope
uh shown here here's the virus particle
with this uh characteristic crown like
morphology
formed by the spike proteins that i'll
talk about in a moment so coronaviruses
are a mem
or a family within the nitovirus order
they're named for the nested set of
sub-genomic mrnas generated during
infection
um oops i have to get used to how this
works um
here's a picture of the coronavirus
particle uh a cartoon
so the coronaviruses have this very long
rna with the cat
five prime n and polyadenylated three
prime end it looks like a
typical eukaryotic messenger rna and
this long
protein this rna is is wrapped up with
the nucleocapsid protein into this
helical structure shown here
called the nucleocapsid the nucleocapsid
is surrounded by a membrane that's
derived from the host cell um and in
that membrane there are three proteins
the spike protein which most people have
heard about now and the spike protein is
really important
in that it moderates uh viral entry um
and it
it's responsible for binding and fusion
of the of the host and viral membranes
during entry
it's also a important determinant of
tropism immune response and virulence
although not the only determinant
the other two proteins in the viral
membrane are the membrane protein and
the small membrane protein
m e is shown here and they also have
important roles in viral
assembly some coronaviruses also
encode a hemoglobin and esterase which
is kind of
homologous to influenza ha that
that protein is not present in sars
coronavirus and related
uh lineage b corona viruses
um okay i'm going to talk a little bit
about the history of coronaviruses so
they've been around for a really long
time they're not
new in 2019 or even in the year 2000 the
coronavirus
research dates back to the uh to the 60s
and late 60s and 70s
and i'm going to call the era since then
an era of study of
mhv mouse hepatitis virus as a model
coronavirus
there are studies of many animal
coronaviruses mostly often focused on
vaccine development
and there are also human coronaviruses
known back from
since that time so the first
coronaviruses we hear about in the
literature are oc43 and 2290
they both cause the common cold although
oc-43 can also cause a little bit more
serious disease in the lower respiratory
tract
and during the 70s 80s and 90s really
there was a lot of research done on
basic coronavirus biology
and it was because of this that when
sars emerged
in 2002 in um in
uh in southern china and started the
path the era of what i call the pathogen
pathogenic human coronaviruses it was
very quickly identified and
characterized because of all that we had
known
uh from the basic biology of studying
these these other uh model viruses and
animal viruses
um so sars uh emerged from uh
bats and transmitted through civets into
humans
it infected about eight thousand people
but only lasted about eight months
because
patients that had sars were easily
identified and isolated
um and and the epidemic really was in in
retrospect was really quite
short um and in the wake of sars um
sars epidemic people looked for more
human coronaviruses and
and identified hku1 and nl63
hku1 causing pneumonia and then l63
causing bronchiolitis and croup
and another notable thing after the
start or the wake of the tsar zero was
that we we really began to understand
that there were many many coronaviruses
in bats as well as other types of
viruses
and then things were pretty quiet until
until 2012 when mers coronavirus emerged
in the middle east
um and mers is still causing infections
it infects people at a much lower rate
it's transmitted it was transmitted from
bats
into camels where it has a reservoir um
and then slowly into humans it's not as
contagious as sars was
then things again required until 2019
when as we all know at the end of the
year uh stars quarter virus emerged in a
different part of china
and caused this worldwide pandemic that
we're all living with right now
so just to be specific sars myrrhs and
soros called v2
all cause severe respiratory disease and
and soros kobe 2 causes coronaviruses 19
or covalent 19.
so it's sort of like hiv and aids stars
kobe 2
virus causes uh covid19 just one more
thing on the timeline
um the first coronavirus meeting met in
wurzburg germany in 1980 i was actually
at that meeting i had just started my
lab
there were only about 60 people there
which was probably most of the field
the 10th meeting met met in the
netherlands in 2003 and there were
hundreds and hundreds of people at this
meeting
as it was just after the sars um
epidemic
and finally we were supposed to have the
15th international meeting now called
the nida virus meeting in the
netherlands in 2020
but it had to be postponed due to the
pandemic
okay i want to talk a little bit about
coronavirus genome structure
so um all these these are showing the
different lineages of coronaviruses that
encode
that include human viruses they're alpha
coronaviruses 2290 and nl63
and the beta corona viruses there are
three lineages a b and c
now called embecco sarbaco and murbeco
um and these include oc43 hku1 and and
the mureen coronavirus that i'll talk
about in a moment that we've worked on a
lot in my lab
uh sars kovi ii kukovi and mirzkovi
all of the coronaviruses have this very
long uh
replicase locus that encodes 16
non-structural proteins which i'll talk
about in more detail
and then the structural proteins in the
same order spike e
m and n um and then what makes these
genomes different
is that uh these uh small non-structural
proteins well i should say
before i get into that sarsko v2 was
easily identified as a mer
as a sarbecca or lineage b virus by its
homology with sars kovi
um and this part of the genome is very
different among all the different
lineages and i'll talk about this in a
lot more detail at the end as well
these small open reading frames tend to
encode um
host antagonist uh activities
okay so um i'm gonna give a really short
very simple uh model of coronavirus
replication it's much
more complicated than this but uh just
to just
for the main points the virus the spike
protein recognizes its receptor on the
host cell membrane
it then mediates um a fusion between the
viral and host membranes releasing the
nucleocapsid into the cytoplasm
the nucleic acid their rna the genome is
translated into a replicase protein
which then makes a amplified genome
shown here
and also transcribes a set of subgenomic
messenger
rnas each one of those rnas is
translated into a protein
these the membrane proteins assemble on
intracellular membrane shown here the s
m and e and the nucleocapsid protein
complexes with new genome
and then buds into this intracellular
compartment the
intermediate compartment between the
endoplasmic reticulum and golgi
and then is found in vesicles shown here
and transported to the cell surface
where it's extruded from the cell
and spike protein is deposited on the
membrane shown here and it mediates a
cell to cell fusion which i'll show a
little bit about
more about later so i want to talk about
several steps in the viral
life cycle several common steps to all
coronaviruses
i'm missing here we're going to talk
about entry but then genome
genome and mrna synthesis and then
translation of conserved replicase
proteins
so viral coronaviruses entry cells uh
by two roots um either the plasma
membrane root shown here directed the
membrane
in this case um the viral after the
virus
uh spike interacts with its receptor
which in the case of sars one and source
two
is angiotensin converting enzymes shown
here
and once that happens a cellular cell
plasma membrane
associated protease cleaves the spike
protein which activates it to mediate
fusion
between the host membrane and the viral
membrane that's shown here
and the nuclear capsule is released into
the cytoplasm
by the second root which is a um
endosomal root the again it's initiated
by the viral spike recognizing its
receptor
uh the viral particle is endocytosed
into an endosome
where it where it's in a low ph
environment which uh which
activates uh cathepsin another protease
to cleave the spike to activate
fusion again there's a fusion between
the viral and
this time the endosomal membrane and the
nuclear capsule is released into the
cytoplasm so the big question is how is
it determined which root is used well
it's a combination of what uh proteases
are available on the cell surface shown
here
tempers for an example what's in the
endosomes cathepsin for an example
and also there is there are
intracellular proteases such as furin
which um can cleave the viral spike
protein as it's being uh synthesized
so that when the viral virus is produced
in
its uh host cell um it comes out already
partially cleaved and ready uh for viral
entry
so i want to give an example from the
mhv system system the marine corona
virus how this works because
not only does it depend on the uh the
proteases but it also depends on the
sequences in the spike protein
so all coronavirus spike proteins have
two subunits
s1 and s2 this is just a jhm's one of
the strains of mouse hepatitis virus
there have to be two cleavages in order
for the spike protein to mediate fusion
one at the s1 s2 border and one at the
s2 prime border the one at the s2 prime
border reveals
of a a hydrophobic peptide
that actually promotes the um viral to
cell fusion
um so some virus some viruses encode
what's called a furan site that's a site
for cleavage by
the protease furan at the s1 s2 border
so a virus like that such as jhm
has this uh purine site and it and the
viral pro
the spike protein is completely cleaved
during during assembly of the virus and
this virus enters the cell only by the
direct plasma membrane group
a closely related virus strain called
mhv2
a lactoferrin site is uncleaved and
enters the cell through the endosomal
group
and a third related strain called a59
has a kind of partial cleavage it has
not quite as good a furion site which is
really just a run of base
basic amino acids um so this virus
enters the cell by both roots
so um and all of these viruses are
perfectly pathogenic so in the mhv
system of pure insight is not
necessarily needed for pathogenesis
um so i and i why is this important it's
it's important because in thinking about
inhibitors
uh an inhibitor such as chloroquine or
another agent that lowers the ph of the
endosome
would only be effective against viruses
entering by the endosomal root
whereas a protease inhibitor for example
chemists at which inhibits tempers too
would only be affected by this root so
since um
any given virus can enters different
cell types by different cell
by different roots or by both roots
sometimes it's really important to
to consider that um what inhibitors will
actually be infective
uh chloroquine will not be effective
against a virus that enters by the
plasma membrane for example
okay i'm going to move on to
transcription of coronavirus rna
so here's the genome rna it's a as i
said very long it's got a five prime cap
and three prime polyadenylate about a
hundred or so nucleotides so-called
leader sequence
and then these transcriptional
regulatory sequences here
that denote the beginning of each
messenger rna
so trans to rna synthesis begins by
translation of an rdrp or or an rna
dependent rna polymerase
which then copies the genome rna into a
negative sense
anti-genome which is then copied back
into more genome rna so that's
replication
at the same time the virus transcribes a
set of sub-genomic
negative sense rnas and the way this
happens is that transcription initiates
at the three-prime endo genome
to here once it reaches the trs the
viral uh
polymerase the rdrp with the nascent
chain jumps
up here and continues uh transcribing
here
to make this very short rna sometimes
that trs is missed
and then the the uh the jump from chance
of transcription
transcribing rna comes from this trs to
the five prime end of the genome
until all of these mrnas are made this
is um the model for
urine coronavirus but it's really the
same for sars or any other coronavirus
and then these sub-genomic rnas are
transcribed back into plus strand
messenger rnas for uh for translation
um and one of the uh things to learn
from from
understanding how these rnas are
transcribed it tells us something about
these rtq pcr detection of coronavirus
rna
that's commonly used for the for the
so-called covalent test
so here's an old gel from 1983 that
demonstrates the rnas of of coronavirus
here's the uh
the nr the smallest rna is always the
most abundant and there's less and less
as they get larger
um so most many of these tests amplify
a portion of the replicase or the rdrp
shown here
as a test for uh for coronavirus
but some of the tests can also amplify
at the end gene shown here
so the difference here is that while
replicase represents only the genome rna
amplification of sequences in the end
gene represent all of the all of the
mrna so that
if you use this um as a test for virus
you're actually
measuring both replicating virus as well
as genome and actually should be more
sensitive
if the virus in these clinical samples
or in these testing samples
is actually replicating which we don't
actually know so you could actually you
could test
whether uh you were having replicating
virus looking at the ratio of
amplifying an end sequence versus a
replica sequence
okay i want to go on now to translation
so each of these mrnas is translated
from its five prime n
into one protein usually occasionally
two proteins
from one mrna but um the really
interesting part of the genome is
translation of the pi prime n
so this is translated into these very
large poly proteins from
open reading frame 1a and 1b they're
called pp1a and pp1b and they eventually
eventually processed into 16
non-structural proteins
and the way this occurs the translation
of both of these polyproteins is via a
frameshift
sequence so translation occurs from the
five-prime end and when it reaches this
frame
sequence it at some frequency it either
terminates translation to to produce
pp1a
or at some frequency it um it actually
it's
it sees this the ribosomes see the
pseudonut uh structure in the rna
and they slip back one reading frame one
uh yeah one reading frame and um
and continue to translate through the
end of pp1a
one a b um and these are processed as i
said during translation into these 16
proteins
now to look at these proteins more
carefully and these are all conserved
among all coronaviruses
these nsps numbered one through 16.
we we see first nsp3 encodes of
papain-like protease
that processes these two sites um
nsp5 encodes a three like three c like
protease the main protease that
processes the rest of the polyprotein
and then nsp12 encodes this rna
rna-dependent rna polymerase
that that carries out replication of
genome and transcription of mrnas
and this interestingly is um is the
target of remdessevier which probably
you've all heard about
and this is a good target because it's
conserved again among all coronaviruses
and any inhibitor should work against
all all the rna rna
dependent rna polymerases um lapinavir
and retinovir have been
tested against the 3c like protease i
don't think they're very successful
uh because they're it's a very different
protease than the uh than the original
protease these were originated
originally designed against um so in
summary
uh we have um a proteases that process
replicates proteins and the rdrp that
replicates genome and transcribed rna
but there are really a whole lot oh
these are just uh these are people that
have actually been looking for
inhibitors all this time way before
stars cov2 so i just
wanted to acknowledge them there there
are a whole lot
more uh proteins conserve proteins
encoded in these open reading frames
um some of them are shown here they're
either proteins that are part of the
replicase complex like a helicase a
primase
but they're also importantly they're
proteins that um
that antagonize host cell responses for
example
there are three proteins involved in
capping the mrna which protects it from
host cell sensors
and makes it look like a like a cellular
host rna
there's also no that prevents the
accumulation of double-stranded rna and
i'll show you in a little minute and a
minute or so
why that's so important but again it's
against host cell responses
this xon is a proofreading enzyme that
prevents the
genome from accumulating too many
mutations and becoming attenuated
um there are also in addition there are
more antagonist activities in cos
encoded in nsp1 and nsp3
so in summary from from this slide these
enzymes there are enzymes to promote
synthesis
and stability of viral rnas capping of
five prime ends of mrnas
and protection from host cell sensors um
and interferon responses and i just want
to show in the next slide
how this works uh an example of how this
can work
so here's um a structure of sars kobe uh
the original source nsp13 the helicase
and here the predicted structures of
mers and uh mhv
nsp13s as well and this was this is an
inhibitor that was used against sars
kovi
sars the original sars and you can see
that it fits into the binding pocket of
all three of these
um structures of these nsp13s and at the
same time
this inhibitor as we shown here as a
function of increasing concentration
can prevent or reduce replication of
both sars mers and
mhv so this is just one example of how
an inhibitor against one virus can be a
panned coronavirus inhibitor
and just to summarize this first part of
the talk
i showed many conserved features of
coronaviruses that can be potential
targets for pan coronavirus inhibitors
and these include sub-genomic mrnas the
non-continuous rna synthesis
the rf1 a1b frame shifting the proteases
the rna rdrp and rna modifying enzymes
and the further activities encoded in
nsp1
there was a macrodomain and a d
ubiquitinase
so now i'm going to really switch and to
the second part of the talk and
and this is something that's different
among different coronaviruses
and that's antagonism of double-stranded
rna-induced antiviral pathways
and um that is usually carried out
by a combination of some of these
conserved
non-structural proteins but also these
small open reading frames encoded in the
three prime end of the genome
and um we know a lot about uh i'm going
to first describe
what i mean by double stranded rna
induced antiviral pathways
and then i'm going to talk about some of
the work that we've done in my lab on
mhv so a linear j virus and mers
coronavirus
lineage c and then at the end i'm going
to talk about our most recent data on
sars kobe 2.
there's much less known about the innate
immune responses encoded or the
antagonists encoded
in the three prime end for these uh
lineage b or sarbaco viruses compared to
the other two lineages
so um so coronavirus double-stranded
rna-induced antiviral pathways are shown
here
so coronavirus or really any rna virus
or any virus enters the cell
the genome is then replicated and
transcribed and in doing so
it generates double-stranded rna that's
shown here and that's
that's um sensed by several sensors or
many sensors in the cell
that that as a danger signal and it
induces the um signaling
these several signaling pathways all
with antiviral activities
so we have here the the canonical
interference signaling pathway
in which double strand rna is sensed by
coronaviruses
it's mda5 and not reguy which signals
through maths to
produce type 1 and type 3 interferons
which then signals through stats
to induce interferon stimulated genes
and cytokine responses in addition
oligoidenolate synthetases
in response to double-stranded rna
synthesize a small oligoadenolate 2-5-a
which catalyzes the dimerization and
activation of rna cell
which cleaves hosts and viral
single-stranded rnas
leading to antiviral activity as well as
cell death and inflammation
and then pkr the third um
the third pathway here senses double
strand rna it autophosphorylates and
dimerizes
then uh phosphorylating eif to alpha
which is the
translation initiation factor and this
leads to translational shutdown
cell death and inflammation and just
as well um inter both oases and pkr
or interferon stimulated genes so
activation of this pathway
can super induce these other two
pathways as well
so now i'm going to first talk about um
the work that we've done in our lab on
uh these
so called two prime five prime
phosphodiester races
encoded in both uh the lineage a viruses
in ns2 and the lineage c viruses in ns4b
just
interestingly these are the only
accessory proteins that are common to
two lineages
in in general these lineage these uh
entrepreneurial antagonizing proteins
are
completely lineage specific so um so
these were the first
uh antagonists we worked on and they're
these are
both members of of this coronavirus
phosphodiesterases are part of a large
super family of 2h phosphoesterases
which catalytic motif types of histidine
x serine threonine x
um shown here is
they they are encoded in different
places in each of these genomes so here
ns2 is encoded in this part of the
genome
and that's um the case also for the
human virus oc
43 the lineage c viruses have this ns4b
shown here
and the toro viruses which are related
nidoviruses also encode a homologous um
phosphodiesterase shown here at the
encoded at the end of the
of orf1a um and
interestingly here's an alignment of
these uh
sequences of these phosphodiester races
members of the
league two uh subfamily and we can see
here that there are
host enzymes a cap7 and um and here's
the mhv the coronavirus enzymes
and the only other virus that encodes a
similar protein are rotaviruses which is
really kind of curious because they're a
completely different kind of virus
so here are the two catalytic motifs
shown here
otherwise they're not highly conserved
so
um here's i'm going to talk about mhv
ns2 now so ns2
is is a phosphodiesterase it has these
two catalytic histidines shown here
we knew before we started this project
that it was a 30 kilodalton protein
expressed in the cytoplasm
not essential for replication in tissue
culture
nor for the central nervous system
pathogenesis caused by mhv so we were
really
perplexed about what this virus did uh
what this
protein did and we were able to get from
a colleague
stuart sadell a wild type and mutant
strain
uh completely congenitic these are
recombinant forces one with a mutation
in ns2
which inactivated the enzyme so we
showed we
we replicated we compared replication of
these viruses
in in macrophages derived from
b6 mice so these are wild-type mice and
we can see here that while wild-type
virus replicates really this is a log
scale up to about 10 to the six
platforming units per unit per
per mil of supernatant the mutant virus
replicated barely at all in these wild
type macrophages however when we
compared replication and macrophages
derived from
from mice with a knockout of the rna
cell gene
the uh virus completely recovered the
mutant virus completely recovered
uh replication so looking at
uh and we also so looking at the this is
here's this pathway again that
oligoadenylate synthetase uh produces
two 5a
which activates rna cell to degrade um
rna and um we can quantify 25a
that's the step of the pathway using a
fret-based
um indirect fret-based assay shown here
so we see that in
um in wild-type infected cells we see a
small amount of 2-5-a produced whereas
in mutant-infected cells we see quite a
lot
we look at the actual activation of rna
cell
by rna integrity on what we call a chip
assay in a bioanalyzer
and that's shown here this instrument
generates a kind of pseudogel
and we can see that in here's mock
infected cells there's 28 and 18s
ribosomal rna
and in cells infected by wild-type virus
we continue to see this
intact rna whereas in mutant infected
cells we can see that the
ribosomal rna now is degraded somewhat
you can see all these bands shown here
so this is how we uh we score activation
of ribose of
rna cell we saw similar data
in our mouse model for hepatitis we can
see here we infect
mice uh intra hepatically the virus
replicates peaking at about day five and
then is cleared by the t
by the t cell response primarily
but and when we looked at replication at
day five which is the peak of
replication
um in b6 in wild-type mice we see that
wild-type virus replicates to about
seven
logs per gram of tissue whereas mutant
virus barely at all
however in the rna cell knockout mice in
the livers we see
robust replication of both viruses we
also see
uh quite extensive antigen staining in
rna cell knockout mice whereas in wild
type mice we see antigen staining only
with the wild type virus
and similarly when we stain with with h
and e we can see there's a
viral induced pathology in the knockout
mice with both viruses
but in the wild-type mice only wild-type
virus is able to cause
any inflammation and and necrosis
so um i just as a sort of uh note which
is really interesting the rna cell
antagonism is not required for
replication and pathology in the brain
while it is in the liver
as you can see here if we infect the
same mice wild type and mutant with the
same viruses
we see similar replication in the brains
of these mice
whether or not they have the um ns2
activity or not
and here's just to show the liver so in
this model we infect mice
intracranially but they infect both
organs and we see this difference in the
liver that i showed you before but
nothing in the brain
and interestingly this is we found out
that this is likely because the
the level of oas um of the oligodeny
synthesis
expressed in the brain is much lower
than in the liver
and that we actually need a sufficient
level of these
um of this of these proteins of these
sensors to activate the pathway
and here's we found that actually that
was true for all the interference
stimulated genes we looked at the brain
has really low levels of expression
compared to the liver
and that's probably to keep the brain
from from undergoing too much
inflammation
that's we'll keep this in mind for later
that that the
activation of these pathways and the
expression of these interference
stimulated genes is quite dependent on
cell type
so just so not only does ns2 antagonize
rna cell but the
mhv nou activity encoded in sp15 which
is
present in all the viruses also
antagonizes rna cell
here's n.o.u we were able to working
with
volcker teal we found that with a
again a wild type and mutant um nsp 15
or nwu
that when we looked at replication in
macrophages for mice again we can see
the same pattern we saw with the ns2
mutant
that the endomutant is really unable to
replicate efficiently
but this occurs by a different mechanism
so volcker teal and susan baker's lab
showed that um
that this endo mutant actually generates
a lot more double-stranded rna than
wild-type virus and you can sort of see
that here
it's not really quantified but um but
staining for double-stranded rna which
is
it which is in green is actually when we
quantify it as much more in the mutant
than the wild type
but we more recently found with uh in a
collaboration with david barton
which is impressed now that the viral
rna is actually cleaved by nw it cleaves
genome plus strand genome
and that's probably the mechanism by
which uh we have a
reduced amount of double-stranded rna
and you can see here there's some this
red stain is for the single-stranded
genome which is so much brighter in
um no mutant-infected cells compared to
wild-type so um
and and we could also see that the endo
mutant
uh activates rna cells shown here here's
intact rna with the wild type
and um and degraded rna with the mutant
however this mutant does not recover
replication in rna cell knockout cells
uh because uh because it also
needs to have the knockout of the pko so
this virus that
this endo mutant produces more
double-stranded rna activating both of
these pathways so we have to have
cells from not knocked out with both of
these pathways in order for the mutant
to recover
so just to summarize here we have the
phosphodiesterases that
prevent this pathway from activating
over here and the endo that by a
different mechanism reduces the amount
of
genome rna which reduces the amount of
double-stranded rna which such down or
slows down all of these pathways
so i next want to talk about uh mers
coronavirus so mers
encodes two uh not two interpure
antagonists in ns4a
which is a double strand rna binding
protein and then ns4b
which again is a 2h diasterase
although this time it's encoded it's in
it has an nls a nuclear localization
signal
and is localized to the nucleus which
was curious um
so we obtain mutants from ralph eric's
lab one
a delta ns4a a delta ns4b
aab um a mutant lacking this nls
sequence and a mutant with a catalytic
histidine
um mutated so that it's an inactive uh
phosphodiesterase we then looked at in
now in a549 human cells respiratory
tract derived human cells
um we looked at uh rna cell activation
with wild type and mutant viruses
and we found that um this is uh
using synbus virus as a control which
robustly activates
um rna cell that um the
nls mutant has no effect on uh
degradation of rna cell but
but um the catalytic mutant now with an
inactive ns4b does induce
a bit of rna cell degradation rna
degradation
um interestingly the ns4a mutant which
is binds double stranded art which
is lacking the double strand rna bind
mutant binding mutant we would have
expected to activate this pathway but it
does not whereas the double
the ns4a b mutant does so ns4a
uh uh was surprisingly um
deleting it was surprisingly had a
surprisingly um
un not a very robust effect now there
was a problem here in showing this slide
that it
somehow got lost in translation of the
system
but what we found here was that uh while
simba's virus robustly activates pkr
phosphorylates that the band is missing
uh ns4a also activates uh pkr
uh but the but the mutant uh the wild
type virus does not the mutant virus
does
um sinvus virus also activates or
phosphorylates pif to alpha but we did
not see that um
in these in the mers-like viruses
you have to imagine the bands here that
i can't show you
um yeah that's shown here okay so uh
we also looked at the activation of uh
interferon
lambda and beta and interference
stimulated genes
in the presence absence of these um
antagonists and we found that while mers
activates uh induces interferon really
really weakly you can see here
um the mutant viruses induced a bit more
these are the mutants lacking 4a and 4b
interference stimulated genes downstream
of interferons are also
pretty weakly activated but again the
mutant virus more than the wild type
demonstrating again
again that these are interfering
antagonists but just for comparison
you can see here that while interferons
are induced or maybe
50-fold at most by interferons induced
by synvis virus to about 10 to the five
fold over background so so these are
really dwarfed
uh inductions compared to another virus
like cinders
so just to summarize this part again
again we have the the
the ns4ab uh antagonizing here the ns4a
here
and uh the nw mutant here um
and uh yeah so i'm so i want to
just review again what we know about
interpreting antagonists so i've talked
to you about
this ns2 protein and s4a and ns4b
and we know for for sars kobe 2 we
really don't know
anything about the antagonists in this
new genome yet
but just we know for by analogy with
sars1 that in source one
this or six protein interferes with
nuclear translocation of stat1
we don't know if sars2 protein does that
because it isn't there are some
differences
and there's an ns3b protein that's been
suggested to be an interference
antagonist but that's not really been
demonstrated within
infectious virus only by over expression
so with that in mind we wonder that
we've been looking at
um the interaction of source cov2 with
with these pathways um so um and we've
used a variety of cell types because we
know that
that these pathways are differentially
activated in different cell types and we
also use synbus virus
as as a kind of positive control and we
use mers kobe too
as a kind of negative control knowing
that it induces so poorly
so um first we looked at uh sars kov2
and mers infection of
a nasal and epithelial derived cells
these are from patients
and we can see here in the red that's
that both viruses
infect these cells this is four
different donor samples
when we looked at replication of these
viruses
we see here that um the black is source
for different patients and the green is
mers that sars replicates somewhat
better than mers and over a longer
period of time in these cell types
we then looked at induction of
interferons and interferon stimulated
genes and we can see that it
that in these cells they're induced
rather weakly shown here
um and uh we did find that um
interestingly that we found undetectable
levels in acetos
of ace2 receptor in these cells the
receptor is clearly there but it
illustrates that you don't need much
receptor
necessarily to infect cells and it was
very low mda5
expression which may be is why we see
such poor
induction here um the next cell type we
looked at were
um were stem cell derived induced
uh alveolar type 2 cells this is the
major cell type infected in the lung
and we know it's a alveolar type 2 cell
by this
surfactant protein c marker shown here
in the in the
red reddish orange here's stars kobe 2
nucleocapsid protein in the green and we
can see that the
cell type is again robustly infected
virus replicates to up to six logs
of infection by two days after infection
um and when we looked at interferon
stimulated genes and interference again
compared to stinbus we see that
generally there's pretty uh
poor expression except for some reason
uh oas2 is expressed quite well in these
cells
um we also looked at activation of rna
cell which we failed to see
in the cell type or in the nasal cells
and here's a western blot where we can
see that
that in this cell type we do see uh
phosphorylation of pkr and
phosphorylation of eif2 alpha suggesting
that the pkr pathway is quite well
activated in the cell type
uh surprisingly and again we see very
poor expression of ace two
in in another primary cell type we then
went on to look at
um uh cardiomyocytes also uh
stem cell derived and they're shown to
be cardiomyocytes by this
troponin t marker shown here in the red
again we see good infection shown by
green expression of nucleocapsid protein
and this time we actually do see some
cytopathic effect that we didn't see in
the other two cell types
you can see there's some cell fusion
here which is typical of coronaviruses
um like three infected cells fused
um we then looked at replication and
again saw robust levels of replication
and finally we looked at isgs and
interference
again and again we see quite weak
induction
um but and no rna cell activation
and again we see um we do see peak hero
phosphorylation and pi
pif to alpha phosphorylation here so
this pathway is again
induced quite well in these cell types
and again
we see poor and poor act expression of
rna cell and mass which may be why we
see such
reconduction of these um pathways and
interestingly we saw that
in the in fact in so in sars-infected
cells we saw a reduction of ace-two
which we actually did see
uh more robustly in um in mock infected
cells and symbols infected cells
so from here we went on to look at um
at uh oh and i i think i'll skip i'll
skip this slide
so we also looked at infection um of two
cell lines that are
that are uh respiratory tract derived
cal u3 cells and a549 cells
which we had to transduce or transfect
or transduce to uh
express the ac2 receptor and that's
shown here
that we infected both of those cell
types and viral cells as well viral
cells are monkey cells usually used to
produce
stocks of the virus and we can see in
the green that virus replicates in all
three cell types
the red is staining double-stranded rna
shown here as expected
it's actually peri-nuclear in the usual
conformation
of seen for virus replication sites
and um we can see very uh extensive
synthetic
or cell fusion in these two cell types
here but not in the bureau cells
and virus replicates well in all these
cell types here's shown viral cells and
h2 cells
i mean a549 ace2 cells and here are cal
u3 cells and you can see that we looked
at replication of sars kovi 2
mers and the mers mutant that i talked
about before the ns4a4b mutant and we
can see that
the mutant replicates poorly compared to
the wild type
and that sars kobe 2 replicates less
well perhaps because it activates some
of these pathways that i'll show you in
a minute
so we then looked at activation of
interferon messenger rna and interferon
lambda and the interference stimulated
genes by our goal by rtq pcr
and we can see that again quite poor
induction of these genes
but some interference stimulating genes
a little bit later in
infection at the second at the 24 at the
48 hours
and here's symbus again rep inducing to
a much greater extent
here we looked at uh induction of p of
stat of
phosphorylation of stat which we did not
see which might
explain the poor induction we also then
we looked at um the same kind of
uh questions in this cal u3 cells and we
saw
something a little bit different in
these cells we can see that
um soros does induce interferon to some
and interferon lambda to a greater
extent and certainly a lot more than
mers
is doing here it's more similar to mers
mutants and the isgs are not are induced
early
in these cell types whereas it was much
later pre in the previous
cell type and also it induces uh the
isgs to a
much greater extent than where's wild
type and even um
to some extent the similar extent to the
mers mutant shown here
and uh when we looked at uh this again
this did not show up properly we did see
phosphorylation of stat one with both
saurus called v2
and the mers mutants so um these data
suggest that this
stars kill v2 is behind it behaving more
like a mars mutant that's missing
its antagonists and then uh
we looked at rna sl activation in both
of these cell types and we can see that
rna cell is activated by sars cov2
in both the a549 cells and in the mers
uh those cal u3 cells and again it's
more similar to the mers mutant that
activates a bit
um and and and more so than mers itself
and here's synbase which activates in
those paths in that cells as well
and then we can't i'm sorry we can't see
this here but
but in summary that both sars cov2
it phosphorylates pkr and eif to alpha
very similar
again to the mars mutant you have to
imagine that those bands are there
and then finally i'm sure one more this
is the last
data slide we also we knocked out uh we
we produce knockout cells in these a549
cells
expressing ii we knocked out uh mavs
um we knocked out rna cell we knocked
out pkr in different cell lines shown
and this is just the western blot to
validate the knockout
we then looked at replication of the
virus in all of these cell types and we
can see that
um in the in the presence or the absence
of rna cell the virus does replicate
slightly better
it's not it's significant it was
statistically significant in three
experiments
and we can see that the rna cell
knockout cells are a lot more cytopathic
effect like the virus is actually
growing better and killing the cells in
the absence of rna cell
and then shown here this is a rna cell
activation in these different cell types
and as expected in the rna cell knock
out cells we see no activation
in the presence of synbis or sars kovi 2
shown here um and this is uh but we do
see activation in the mavs and the pkr
knockout cells and this is of interest
because it shows
that the mavs mass dependence signaling
pathway interferent pathway
is not required for activation of rna
cell so this pathway can be activated
quite robustly even when
interferon signaling is shut down shown
by this map's knockout cells
so in conclusion or just the summary of
the data
we have these four ns2 and ns4b
antagonists knocking down this pathway
or preventing activation
we have the ns4a double strand binding
protein
uh slowing these pathway styles but not
that but loss of it is not very
effective in activating pathways
we have the orf six from sarsko v2 that
works at this level
we don't know whether that's working at
the level of source this is source code
v1 i'm sorry
at source code 2 because we do know that
source code b2 can promote
phosphorylation of pstat
of stat 2 stat1 sorry and then we have
the
endo you uh that really is present in
all of these viruses
and is is at is preventing the the or
slowing down the accumulation of
double-stranded rna
so the source cov2 at least has this
protein i don't know that it's been
shown yet to be active but it most
likely is by its sequence
so we still don't know really uh so we
don't know really very much or anything
about
um interferent antagonist proteins in
stores kobe 2
but we have shown that it does seem to
allow more activation of the pathways
than the other two viruses that we've
worked with so
in conclusion coronaviruses enter the
cells by two pathways
uh the pathway used depends on spike
protein on protease cleavage sites
and on hosts and hosts and surface and
intracellular proteases
coronaviruses express numerous conserved
host antagonists in the replicase locus
often enzymes these are potential
targets for antivirals that may be
effective against most
if not all coronaviruses lineage a and
lineage c
beta corona viruses express accessory
proteins that contribute to antagonism
of activation of rna cell interferon
signaling
and isgs as well as pkr
uh source cov2 like mers weakly induces
interferons however sargasso b2 lacks a
pde a phosphodiesterase
and a double-stranded rna binding
protein and
activates rna cell promotes
phosphorylation of pkr
and stat in some cell types of course
and these data suggest then that sars is
not as adept as mers
in shutting down double-stranded rna
into his pathways
and finally we speculate does this or we
ask the question
does this have any contribution to the
ability of sars
to spread uh asymptomatically um
and i will stop oh i want to acknowledge
my lab
these are the members of current members
of the lab these are past members of the
lab that have been really fundamental in
setting up
all this all this murs and mhv2 work
um and these are our many uh important
collaborators and our
funding and i just want to show how our
lab has transmitted or transformed from
looking like that to looking like that
most recently
and um i will stop here
and take questions
thank you
and thank you dr formative presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar
and if you have any questions
please do so now yeah and
doctor i'm going to ask you to click on
that i think you just took it off
perfect
just click on that question oh
wait a second let me get rid of this
yeah
perfect now i okay
i don't see the answer okay oh
it's still echoing what's that going
oh you hear the echoing oh
i don't know perfect thank you so much
um just click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen so let's get started
dr weiss we have quite a few questions
already coming in okay which is exciting
um can we expect another coronavirus
outbreak
in the near future and if so how might
we be able to prevent another
coronavirus
outbreak okay so um i don't know
yeah we can expect one i we have no idea
when or where i
i i often say this and i forgot so we
only know of three but there might have
been a lot of other ones that we don't
know about because they didn't cause
such a
they didn't cause people to die or a
pandemic so it actually may have crossed
over quite a lot because we do know
that there are a lot of coronaviruses in
in bats
um i don't know that i mean the way we
can prevent it i i guess is keeping
the bats away from people but but um i
think having an
armament of antivirals would be
incredibly important so that if we do
get
um another outbreak we have something to
use before we get a vaccine
thank you so much and is there any
neurological impact
of the sars cov2 as in
mers virus okay so there's
there's been a lot of talk about that so
we know that there are neurological
complications or neurological symptoms
in in some fraction of patients
um and i and there's a lot of i mean my
lab in fact is interested in this too
but
it's not really clear yet what whether
um sars kov2
infection actually occurs in the brain
or whether it's kind of a secondary
infection of inflammation but there's
there's something there and and
i think there are quite a lot of people
that are looking at that now
thank you very much and again i want to
thank our audience members for these
great questions
does the source of interferon the tissue
or blood cells
dysfunctional and is there an impact on
the
isg response um
well okay so the paradigm is that during
early infection
both in humans and in um animal models
that that that it the viruses behave
like what i just showed it
pretty much shuts everything down
although sars kobe do too doesn't seem
to do it quite as well
and then there's some kind of
dysregulation later where cytokines
are kind of go crazy and i think i'm
trying to
it could be because during early
infection in the human there's a lot of
virus replication and then
by the time someone is really sick in
the hospital the amount of virus that
can be isolated is not so high and it's
then at that point that the cytokines
take off
so i'm just speculating that maybe um
after infection there's a lot of debris
and
rna or proteins that that are that can
hang around and induce
interferons and other cytokines so yeah
i guess in that sense there's some
dysregulation
thank you so much and dr weiss in view
of the sequence
homology do neutralizing antibodies
toward stars kovi one and or
mers have neutralizing activity against
stars
cov2 okay so certainly not for mers i
would say because
mers is a different lineage it's a
different
it's more different so stars one and
stars two are more similar than is mers
um i'm you know i'm not sure about stars
one and stars two
i would think that perhaps they would
cross-react
um i always thought it'd be interesting
to see if people
that had sars one would be immune to
sars would have antibodies that would
neutralize sars2 but
i'm not really sure i would think there
will be some cross reaction
but we never really developed vaccines
for sars one they were sort of
developed and then kind of aborted when
the virus went away
thank you so much we have time for a few
more questions
why are some patients infected by
thesaurus kovi
induced a poor interferon
response and it but then an increase in
chemo
um kind storm well
i don't i don't know the answer to that
i would really like to know the answer
i would really like to know the answer
to that but i don't know i think that's
something people are certainly looking
at
definitely now after immune system has
been activated by stars cov2
and spike proteins have been cleaved by
the proteins
are there additional targets for the
spike protein that might contribute
to the cytokine storm i think we really
don't know
um i you mean like like once this
so so you were thinking maybe when the
after the cell is lysed that
it releases spike i don't know spike
proteins on the surface it's going to be
part of the lysis that will be around so
i don't know the answer to that
i guess it's possible thank you
we have time for one more question the
parameters you studied with the in vitro
cells
do they necessarily correlate with what
occurs
in vivo no so so so i think from what i
showed and i'm sorry i went through very
quickly and i was missing some of those
bands but
but you don't see the same activation in
in all the cell types even among the
cell the um the cell lines and certainly
among the primary cells
but but i think that in vivo uh the the
virus is going to encounter a lot of
different cell types and so it's going
to be different in different cell types
so
you can't translate from the from the
cell lines directly to
to the primary cells on the other hand
each primary cell is going to be very
different in terms of
both entry which pathway it enters by
and also which
what level of isgs or what kind of
pathways are going to be responding so
no you're right you can't really
translate from one to the other on the
other hand it's important i think it's
important to look at different cell
types
to see the variety of possibilities
dr weiss thank you for your presentation
today would you like to provide any
closing remarks before we go
um i'll i'll make a couple so i i do
think that um
sort of the question about whether
they're going to be more i think that
it's
that we have to be prepared for more so
i have several recommendations that we
certainly need a vaccine
right for this pandemic we need to keep
pursuing antivirals for
um for this virus and for future and and
future coronaviruses and i think it's
important to keep looking
out in bats and finding out what really
is what viruses are in bats because some
of them look like they can really
they can transmit to humans pretty
readily and my last thing is kind of a
wish list that
um we really have to keep uh continuing
to fund basic
basic virology base understanding these
viruses because
i mean i've worked on these viruses for
40 years and they've always been
considered like who cares about them
and um we should have cared about them
more
so thank you absolutely thank you dr
susan weiss
thank you so much for your presentation
today and before we go i want to thank
the audience for joining us
for today and they're interesting
questions and any questions we did not
have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
for the contact information that you
provided at the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
for six months up to
march 2021 next year lab routes will
alert you
via email when it's available for replay
we encourage you
to share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time take care be safe
stay healthy bye everyone